damn after the game the emotion and
anger you
showed and saying put respect to my name
who was that directed at
whoever has something to say was there
anybody in the arena that
in particular it was just a bunch of
people on that
on the opposite side that press roll
area and uh
those are people who usually have
something to say or put out whatever
they put out so
it was just in that direction
next question is coming from dave
mcminiman with uh espn
hey dame uh there are some names in the
sport
of basketball that resonate a little bit
more uh wilt chamberlain is
kind of that paul bunyan larger than
life category
today you joined him as one of the only
two players in league history to have
360
point games in the same season and i'm
curious your thoughts on that
accomplishment
i'm just i mean i'm i'm first of all i'm
happy to be in that type of company you
know that's
an honor and i'm also happy that it came
you know two of the three came in the
winning effort and you know tonight
it couldn't have been better timing for
that type of game so
um like i said it's it's a pleasure and
a honor to be in company with will
you know and hopefully you know it can
continue
the next question is coming from casey
holdahl with trailblazers.com
damian uh can you talk about what you
were thinking and feeling in that fourth
quarter uh obviously you guys
aren't able to get a field goal i think
until midway through the quarter you're
able to get to the line but that's about
the only thing you got going
so what's going through your mind at
that time and also what are you thinking
when you see that
that shot bounce off the rim go 20 feet
and then go back down
um well i've when i let it go i shot it
real straight you know i was like well
that's that's online and i thought it
was going to go in so we
hit back rim and went straight up
i kept watching it because i was like i
think that's going to go in and
it dropped in but uh you know i think
that was
you know my cousin you know rest in
peace chef b i think that was him
dropping that in for me
next question is coming from chris
mannix with sports illustrated
then when when cj's struggling with the
shot the way he did tonight when he goes
to three through lines those last two
shots are huge
at the end do you say anything to him do
you feel like he already has the
confidence that he
even on a tough shooting night he could
step in and make him i think one thing
that
um is a part of our relationship and
something that
uh makes us have so much belief in each
other he knows that i have
unwavering confidence and i know the
same thing about him you know i know
i know his heart i know his toughness um
i know who he is as a man so
um in that situation i was like this my
opportunity to make up for the free
throws last time so i'm gonna try to
break to the ball
but i saw how they set up their defense
and they was gonna try to deny me
and i went up to him before we even
before the referee handed the ball over
and i said if i can't get the ball
you have to get the ball and he did that
he made the free throws um
i don't expect anything different from
him um
you know he's a little bit banged up you
know he's making no excuses
we're looking for no way out he's you
know dugging it out for the team and
being out there for us
and uh fortunate for us him doing that
he was out there for those last free
throws and came through for us